a non-profit helps a metro officer
adjusting to a new normal
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in the student newsroom
rather with the circumstances and the
special gift he and his daughters
received today
kristin sasha metro officer john lopez
recently lost his
ex-wife to covet 19 leaving him to raise
their
two daughters full time now but a
non-profit wants to help ease his stress
this holiday season
i wasn't expecting anything like this a
special delivery via motorcycle
riders with the blue knights
international law enforcement motorcycle
club pull into metro headquarters
bringing some holiday cheer to help
officer john lopez
we hear you've gone through a little bit
of a hard time
we feel for you the blue knights
choosing lopez to receive their annual
christmas check donation
we're here for you we'll always be
around for anybody to help out
community support following the sudden
loss of his ex-wife to covet 19
leaving lopez to raise his 16 and 11
year old daughters
while caring for his father who suffers
from dementia
i had a movement with me full time and
now there's just the adjustment
of you know getting by knowing that you
know
you know that their mom's not going to
be around anymore but the blue knights
want to show
he's not alone we want to help our own
to let them know that
no matter what goes on they're not
forgotten you know it's just because you
have a hard time
we're not pushing you away we are here
for the hard times and the good times
the group also giving lopez a gift
basket popcorn and presenting his
daughters with envelopes of money
we gave 200 to the kids as we want them
to feel that
it's not just about dad it's just really
cool that you know we're thinking of us
and did this making the day memorable as
lopez and his family cope with their new
normal
you know you may not like what happened
in life but you have to accept what
happened
and you just have to learn how to move
on and go through it
this was the third year the blue knights
presented this type of gift
they gave the family 500 dollars total
along with other donations made by the
community